what does it mean to be human why are we
here at all in the first place why is
there a universe you will never answer
those questions from within a logical
scientific framework the answers come to
us from mythology the right brain works
in images where we get messages in our
dreams
every mishlov's Journey began in 1968
sparked by a powerful dream despite
academic taboos he earned a doctorate in
parapsychology so did Susan Blackmore by
the way Jeffrey's theories like Arthur
Young's reflexive universe theory
proposed as a hierarchical structure of
evolution suggesting untapped human
growth now how does Jeffrey reconcile
that with evolutionary understanding we
explore that in studying Consciousness
he adopts some active Observer approach
attempting to integrate scientific
objectivity with an experiential
understanding so it's not science per se
and it's not meditative per se one
discussion involves a psychic predicting
UFO sightings including a widely
witnessed event how can such claims be
objectively verified again we explore
that on the personal development side
Jeffrey emphasizes the importance of
what he calls a strong ego prior to
spiritual growth warning against
prematurely sacrificing ego which can
lead to being stuck in a state of
quote-unquote false Enlightenment this
podcast had several editing challenges
on both the audio and the video front
particularly with mine as we just didn't
have it I don't know if you've seen the
podcast of myself being interviewed by
Ryan Graves on the merged podcast but
what he did was he resurrected with AI
the episode at least with the audio side
we had to Cobble something together in a
similar Manner and it'd be a shame to
not release it what you're witnessing is
akin to a classified episode that's
finally being uploaded my name is
karchay Mongol and this podcast is
called theories of everything where we
explore theories of everything from a
physics perspective primarily though I'm
dipping my toes more and more so to
speak into Consciousness studies and
attempting to decipher the hard problem
of Consciousness as well as what role
does Consciousness have on either
engendering or supervening on the laws
of physics enjoy this hitherto
unreleased podcast with Jeffrey mishlov
the creator of new thinking aloud Linked
In the description to that
all right Jeffrey mishlov welcome to the
theories of everything podcast could you
kindly unwind your journey into the
realm of parapsychology as I've been
reflecting on it I realized that
probably my first introduction to this
world of the Paranormal and the esoteric
began in 1968 even a few years before I
I had some powerful dreams that really
changed my life but the stage was set in
1968 when I was a graduate student
attending summer school at the
University of Wisconsin at Milwaukee
and I remember I was sitting in the
cafeteria one afternoon and a man walked
up to me handed me a flyer and I looked
at the flyer it said spiritual science
a lecture on spiritual science and at
that moment I felt like a current of
electricity running up and down my spine
I'd never seen those two words
juxtaposed like that spiritual science
and it turned out the lecture was about
the Austrian Mystic Rudolph Steiner and
his the movement he had founded called
anthroposophy so I attended the lecture
I got to meet people in the
anthroposophy community
and as a result of that I I went back
for my senior year in Madison at the
University of Wisconsin and I elected to
write a senior thesis on the psychology
of religious mysticism and really I went
into it as a skeptic I thought there
must be some
psychopathologies associated with people
who think that they're having mystical
experiences Freud had already described
this as kind of a return to an infantile
State of Consciousness and people who
thought they saw ghosts so I'd write it
up that way but the more I researched it
the more I came to realize
their Mystics
were some of the most important people
in our culture and in fact I I got in
touch with the work of Abraham Maslow a
psychologist who wrote the book covered
a psychology of being in which he had
interviewed some of the most important
people in our culture in his era people
like Albert Einstein and Eleanor
Roosevelt and he found that they already
report what called Peak experiences that
were Central to their lives and also he
added these Peak experiences are
indistinguishable from mystical
experiences so with that
understanding I could no longer feel
comfortable debunking the Paranormal and
the esoteric but then I went on to
graduate school in criminology
at Berkeley and it was some four years
later in 1972
that my great uncle Harry
visited me that's the best way I can
describe it he visited me in a dream
literally at the moment of his death and
that dream was so powerful that I I woke
up from the dream and I was just crying
tears of joy and singing
a very sacred song from my religious
background and I wrote Oh I said how's
the Larry I had a dream about him and my
mother called me as soon as she got my
letter she said how did you know Uncle
Harry just died
uh that really Shook Me Up it made me
realize something's going on here that I
don't understand and I asked for an
object of Uncle Harry something he had
owned so I could think of him and
remember him I was sent a a little book
and and I was told this was Uncle
Harry's favorite book it was a book
written in Yiddish a very obscure
language that European Jews
spoke it's kind of a written in the
Hebrew script but the language is more
like German and
I had to get it translated I realized
after having a a translated for me that
it was called the tales of the balchem
Tov who is the founder of the Jewish
City
uh
movement right in the 18th century it
was a very powerful mystical movement
within Judaism and it was then that I
came to realize that my great uncle
Harry
had been a Mystic I I always known that
he was a very religious man a Pious
person an orthodox Jew but now I was
introduced to the the mystical side of
Judaism and
as a result of that contact
I felt that I had to change my
my trajectory my career trajectory I had
to move away from criminology at the
time I was doing volunteer work at San
Quentin prison working with murderers
and rapists and the psychiatric unit
doing group therapy with them and and I
made a decision as a result of the dream
with Uncle Harry that I was going to
switch somehow I would find a way to see
the positive side of human deviance
rather than the negative that I would be
studying
intuition creativity mysticism psychic
phenomena the esoteric and occult and I
didn't of course have any idea as as to
how this could be done there weren't any
programs of this sort that the
University of California which is a
large major university so I anguished
about this for months trying to figure
out what am I going to do and
one day
in I recall correctly was probably
November probably about six months after
the Uncle Harry dream
when
I had another dream and not only did I
have another dream but I knew in advance
that I was going to have a dream that
evening I just it was a knowing an
intuition and
I knew that the answer to all my
searching it was going to come to me in
a dream that evening
so I I was ready for it you might say
after months of Anguish and I did have a
dream I woke up I was exhilarated I knew
I had found the answer in the dream but
I didn't know what the what it meant the
dream in in the dream I was visiting
friends in Berkeley people I knew well
knocked on the door of their apartment
and married student housing
no answer and in the dream I found a key
let myself into their apartment walked
into the living room where I found right
in the middle of the living room floor a
magazine in the dream called i e y e and
I'm paging through the magazine
and then I woke up with this feeling
like that's it I have the answer but of
course I had no clue
so I acted out the dream I put on my
tennis shoes ran five miles across town
came to this apartment
knocked down the door as I had dreamed
no answer and in fact I knew that they
kept the key under the doormat so I
picked up the key entered the apartment
walked into the living room and there
smack dab in the middle of the living
room floor just as I had dreamed was a
magazine and this is an example I
suppose of a dream Distortion it wasn't
called I it was called Focus
and it was the magazine of listener
sponsored radio and television and the
San Francisco Bay Area KQED and I'm
paging through the magazine when it
dawned on me for the first time in my
life that I could pursue my interests if
I got involved in the non-profit
non-commercial segment of the media so
because I lived in Berkeley I went over
to the Pacifica Radio station there
which is also non-profit
kpfa and said I'd like to volunteer and
at that point I had already earned my
my master's degree in criminology but
they said here sit down at this desk and
when you hear the doorbell ring push
this button so people can get in the
front door and I gladly did that at the
same time I learned how to produce a
radio program I produced a program
called you don't have to be from out of
town to be psychic because I knew a lot
of Psychic Friends in Berkeley and I
interviewed them and the program
director liked it so much he said we
have a regular slot for you every
Tuesday and Thursday at noon uh we want
you to host a program called the mind's
ear So within a few weeks of this dream
I found myself
sitting across a table from world-class
experts in all the areas that interested
me the most people on book tours passing
through San Francisco came by that radio
station with a very powerful signal and
I would be interviewing them with 10 000
people listening in so that gave me the
confidence to go back to the university
where I was still a graduate student in
criminology and switch over taking
advantage of a very obscure program they
had the individual
interdoctoral major program where if you
want to do a dissertation if you're
already a graduate student in good
standing which I was
and you want to work in a field where no
department will sponsor you but you can
find three faculty members from
different departments who will each
sponsor you
you can create your own unique degree
programs so that would have been 1973 by
then I entered that program and uh
stayed in it until I graduated with a
doctoral degree in parapsychology in
1980 and to this
day 43 years later I'm not aware of any
other example of an accredited
University issuing a doctoral diploma
that says parapsychology on it may maybe
I'm mistaken but I always have to point
out there are truly hundreds of people
who have done
dissertations doctoral level
dissertations on parapsychological
topics they just done it within
departments that were willing to sponsor
them typically their degrees were in
Psychology or philosophy or education
something like that
why did you choose an academic approach
to studying the Paranormal and how can
one apply the scientific method in this
field I could have
pursued it as a hobby which I suppose I
had up until uh that point but I was
very serious I wanted to get to uh what
had actually happened when I had this
powerful dream of my great uncle
visiting me it's the most powerful dream
I've ever had in my life and I'm 76
years old so
uh you know if you have one dream like
that in your lifetime it can change you
dramatically and it was so profound I
felt that it was worth devoting the rest
of my life to studying it and and I I
guess you would have to say I'm an
intellectual person I I've always
enjoyed knowledge and I've always felt
very comfortable in a university
environment even though the universities
in general have not welcomed studies in
in this field
I mean that's why 43 years later no
other degrees in parapsychology have
ever been awarded there there is a taboo
against it with in Academia and to be
honest I had to fight very hard the
closer I got to completing my doctoral
program at Berkeley the more obstacles
were thrown at me and I had to you know
overcome each and every obstacle and
then even after I received my degree the
organized groups of people who call
themselves Skeptics but are really
scoffers in in my view tried to pressure
the university to revoke the degree uh
nearly succeeded one Dean put it to me
very starkly he said universities do not
offer degrees in parapsychology Period
so they tried to undo it and I had to
fight a legal battle
which I prevailed in and and then
another legal battle because I I had
been liable after they failed to get the
degree revoked an article appeared in
Psychology today magazine claiming that
maybe the degree hadn't really been
awarded at all but if it had been
awarded it certainly wasn't deserved and
and I fought a a libel battle uh at that
point six years of uh legal wrangling
which ended favorably for me so uh my
passion has been the intellect my
Approach has has been intellectual I
think that uh you can approach the
Paranormal in many different ways some
people are
more heart centered I suppose you could
say and I think that's all very
important but uh for me understanding
what's going on intellectually has been
at the heart of my quest and uh of
course
being on uh non-commercial radio where I
started and now YouTube where I have a
channel and before that on National
Television public television or around
the country it's it's always been my
desire to share what I've learned
intellectually with the public at Large
whose insights have been particular in
shaping your understanding of
parapsychology
it's a very difficult question
to answer who is the most impactful yes
to be because when I do the interviews
it's very much about being in the here
and now being fully focused and present
with with whomever I'm with so each time
I'm with somebody they are the most
important person uh but if I look back
I I would say that uh starting in in the
very early work that I did there were
people who became very important mentors
for me who were also guests on the early
programs that that I did one such person
was Arthur M Young Who was a really
crucial person in in my development he's
the founder of the what was them called
The Institute for the study of
Consciousness he was a cosmologist the
author of many books the reflexive
Universe the geometry of meaning the
Bell notes he was also when I say the
Bell notes that was about his work with
bell aircraft because Arthur Young was
the inventor of the Bell Helicopter the
very first commercially licensed
helicopter and uh after he invented the
helicopter he felt that he had earned
the right to delve into philosophy he
felt that in in his era all of
philosophy had failed to really
anticipate and grapple with the rise of
Science and Technology in the 20th
century and that if you really wanted to
be a philosopher worth your salt you
first had to demonstrate that you could
Master a difficult technological problem
and so he set out and when he graduated
from Princeton in
1926 as I recall he set out to find a
problem that he could solve he went to
the patent office in Washington DC and
he discovered there had been 200
attempts to build or to design an
aircraft that could hover in midair and
he realized it hadn't been accomplished
yet he would work to try and accomplish
it so between 19
26 and the first Bell aircraft model 47
in 1947. he worked for nearly 20 years
uh on the helicopter problem
only to proved that he would then be
worthy to be a philosopher and at that
point he got into cosmology he was
deeply interested in psychic phenomenon
and astrology he had the means to travel
the world and examine every interesting
example in his era of psychic
functioning and created a journal the
journal for the study of Consciousness
and opened up this institute in Berkeley
where he invited me and my good friend
Saul Paul sirach to move in and and
become his direct students so at the
same time that I entered by Paris
psychology program I had this remarkable
gentleman as a mentor a person of vast
knowledge and who had developed what you
are promoting a Theory of Everything
Arthur Young's reflex universe is a
theory that encompasses all of the
sciences and mythology and our deep
knowledge of esoteric functioning and
paranormality and and addresses what you
could call First principles in
philosophy which are the most difficult
of all to address so he he was a very
wonderful man and a great influence on
me
another very important early influence
person who I interviewed was Gene
Houston the psychologist who had founded
a mystery School
something that was a modern version of
the ancient teachings of the ellucinian
Mysteries and again this was an effort
to educate people about the world's
great spiritual traditions and Gene had
an Exquisite sense of humor her father
was a professional humorous to wrote for
people like Sid Caesar and many many of
the Great comics in the early years of
Television so Gene had a fabulous
ability to
invoke a theatrical presence she
actually based a lot of her work on the
uh theatrical techniques of stanislavski
the the idea of an actor embodying the
character that that they become in the
theater and that was her approach into
into the Paranormal and it was an
incredibly profound and exhilarating at
the same time I give you one example
when I attended Gene Houston's mystery
school on one occasion
she was giving a lecture on the Hebrew
cabalan based on the writings of
the early 20th century kabbalist Carlos
Suarez who had written a book called the
cipher of Genesis and she was explaining
to the group using kabbalistic
principles how
it was that God created the world in
Hebrew the sentence is uh I don't know
which translated means in the beginning
God created the Heaven and the earth and
the kabbalistic idea is if you go
through the Hebrew words letter by
letter and understand the meaning of
each letter because each letter is also
a word and has a meaning
that you will understand
the very process by which the universe
was created and as she was lecturing
felt like I got it I understood at a
deeper level this impulse of God to
create a universe and I thought it was
the funniest thing in the world
actually it struck me as nothing could
be more hilarious than God creating the
universe and I was literally rolling on
the floor laughing and tears are coming
down my eyes and uh Gene Houston noticed
this and and she came up to me and
winked
and said oh you're having an epiphany
huh
she understood that she had an enormous
gift and still does she's a great
teacher still alive working today an
enormous gift to engender
moments of Spiritual Awakening in the
people with whom she works she
understood it I think as a psychological
process that there were psychological
techniques available to all of us to
awaken a deeper sense she used to say
for example
that the human organism is incredibly
Exquisite it's like a Stradivarius
violin but most people only learn to
play it as if it were a plastic fiddle
but you could learn you could learn to
work with your organism to achieve
something more like a a concert violin
and so
that had just an enormous impact on me
as I began my work those are two of the
most influential people in my life
what's the reflexive model of the
universe
Arthur Young's model of the reflexive
starts with the idea of spirit
descending into matter
and it goes through four stages as it
descends into matter you could say it
starts out at the level of the photon
which in his view is pure Spirit pure
light and God said let there be light in
the beginning so to speak and then from
the photon we get
articles typically yeah
positrons electrons and protons
so you have positive and negative charge
that comes next and he saw that as being
equivalent to the development of emotion
attraction and repulsion that emotions
come and then you get after you have
particles like that you get atoms atoms
for him represented form form intellect
so emotion comes before intellect and
then intellect evolves with the very
first atoms and uh of course from atoms
we get molecules and and molecules uh
the most important molecules would be
DNA and RNA the molecules of life itself
now that's a turning point because at
that point with the development of DNA
RNA molecules Consciousness is already
embedded in matter
but then matter itself evolves you you
get the single-celled organisms you get
Plants you get animals you get the human
Kingdom so uh there's a turning point
The Descent of spirit into matter and
then the ascent of spirit from matter
back to Spirit and and it's the
evolution then of the human being
towards what you might think of as
spiritually evolved being
his system is very complex and it
corporates you can think of it as
the periodic table of the elements in
chemistry but apply to everything the
Periodic Table of of everything and in
that periodic table he would say the
modern human being
stands in relationship to who we become
our potential as a fully realized human
would be equivalent then you could see
it all laid out in these charts of his
to where a clam stands in relationship
to the Animal Kingdom in other words if
a human being if as an animal if we
represent the epitome of what an animal
can become then we are like clams as as
far as the possibilities for Being Human
that there's so much growth available to
us untapped attention
how should we conceptualize
Consciousness within this model
well Arthur Young had a view that um
I would be consistent with the idea that
he called the Great chain of being which
does represent a hierarchy that you have
uh animals being more evolved than
plants for example because they have the
quality of Mobility that plants don't
have and humans more evolved than
animals and some humans more evolved
than than other humans so it was very
hierarchical in that sense and I will
say that I had another Mentor Dean Brown
I had the great pleasure of introducing
them at one time Arthur Young and Dean
Brown Dean was a physicist he he had
worked with Einstein at The Institute
for advanced studies at Princeton and he
also became a good friend and a mentor a
a great student of the world's
religious Traditions he published a book
of his translations of the upanishads
for example and he differed with Arthur
Young on this idea of hierarchy he said
that
there's no reason to think animals are
more evolved than plants it could be the
other way around after all the plants
get the animals to do their work for
them such as Distributing their seeds
and and so on that it might be that
plants are a higher life former than
animals which gave me an appreciation
for the fact that you can often see
things for for every supposed truth that
you might come upon there could be an
equal and opposite truth looking looking
in the other direction it's a
particularly valuable lesson I think in
when it comes to the world of politics
where people get very very locked into
particular ways of of looking at the
world so uh I've often found for myself
at least it's very useful to have a
flexible mind a way of seeing things uh
from both perspectives I sometimes tell
myself you want to be the lawn and the
lawn mower at the same time it's it's
good to understand
both the ups and the Downs of of life
what is archetypal synchronistic
resonance
it was I believe in 2007 that I you know
published an article co-authored with
Brendan Angus and it was published in
the Journal of humanistic psychology and
called archetypal synchronistic
resonance
this Story begins many many years before
that
I guess I would take it back to my early
years in television in the original
thinking aloud public television series
I interviewed uh Marty Rossman a medical
doctor in Mill Valley California who was
a specialist in hypnosis
and
he was going to introduce me to the idea
of getting in touch with your inner
healing advisor
so uh we recorded this the whole thing
is on video where Marty Rossman is
hypnotizing me and he's saying and now
you're inner healing advisor will appear
and in my mind
I saw a man approaching me wearing a
toga
and I thought to myself hmm I'd like to
improve my public speaking abilities so
I'd like this inner healing advisor to
be demosthenes the great Greek orator
who could help me with my speaking
abilities and as this in individual
approached me in my mind
and I'm expecting it now to have a
conversation with demosanies
he said to me I'm not demasthenese and I
said well who are you he said I'm Seneca
I didn't know much about Seneca it's a
name you hear you know some ancient
person at poet playwright
philosopher I knew very little about
Seneca but I asked him in this hypnotic
experience well now that you're here in
your Seneca you're my healing advisor
what would you like me to do
and he said
study my life
which was
that was
um
and I I woke up I came out of the trance
that's all on video I had this silly
grin up my face because it felt so real
and I explained what had happened and I
began studying the life of this ancient
Roman Statesman philosopher playwright
and I realized that after studying two
things first of all he was one of the
most interesting people I'd ever
encountered in history he literally ran
the Roman Empire for five years he was
the tutor to Nero when Nero was still a
youngster and as Nero's tutor tutored to
the emperor he ran the Empire and it was
known as The Silver age of Rome one of
one of the best periods in Roman history
but he also wrote plays and he wrote a
great deal of philosophy he was one of
the leading stoic philosophers and
at the end of his life he got implicated
as being part of a conspiracy to murder
Nero now he wasn't really part of the
conspiracy but apparently the conspiracy
centers wanted to install him as the
emperor once they get away with Nero
because he had such a reputation and
Nero learned about all of this and
quashed the conspiracy and sent a
centurion to order
Seneca to take his life
Seneca is at a dinner party at the time
and
the Centurion comes in with orders from
the emperor you you have to take your
life and
Seneca looks at him he says can I at
least make out my last will and
testament the Centurion says no no time
for that if to take your own life and do
it now so Seneca turned to his guests at
the dinner party and he said I decree to
you my life
study my life those were his last words
and and I had such a
shock of realization when it occurred to
me that his very last words were the
ones that I heard him speak in this
hypnotic experience so he he became a
very important influence in my life
well years later Brendan Engen who I
didn't know the co-walk who became the
co-author with me of this paper said he
had had a psychic reading from a
Channeler named Kevin Ryerson Uh Kevin
happened to have been my friend and knew
all about the Seneca story and he said
Kevin told him
that I had been Seneca in a past
Lifetime and that he had been
uh seneca's uh writing partner I think
named lucretius Seneca wrote many
letters to lucretius that were letters
of advice and have been published and uh
and so on and he he said to me well
maybe we knew each other in a past life
and I wrote back and said no I don't
think so I don't believe I was Seneca uh
Seneca is a hero to me yeah but I didn't
think that it could be an example of
synchronicity that there's some
synchronistic connection and the reason
I say that in particular is because the
day I got the email from Brendan Eng and
I was traveling I was actually
going to Spain at the time uh to visit
the Cordova in Spain which is the city
where Seneca was born where there's a
big statue of Seneca and I thought that
synchronistic that he'd approached me
and and at the very moment I'm traveling
to the birthplace of Seneca so we
interacted for quite a while and it
turned out many different
synchronicities began happening between
myself and Brendan that seem to support
this idea of somehow a synchronistic
connection with a historical person it
didn't mean that we were those people in
our past lives but that there was a
resonance
that expressed itself through
synchronicities uh on one occasion for
example Brendan angen
went to visit a bookstore and a book
literally fell off the bookshelf and hit
him on the head and he picked it up and
he saw on the it was a book called The
Looking Glass God but when he opened the
book up he saw my name in it it had been
my book I had sold it apparently to this
bookstore and it fell on his head and so
he and I
agreed at that point we would co-author
a paper that this was in effect a new
theory of the Paranormal especially
around for people who felt they had a
past life connection with
important historical figures uh that it
might be another way of looking at at
least some cases of reincarnation and
because I still don't think
I was Seneca in a past life although I
will say this because
I look to see what what would confirm
that would be if I actually had memories
of being Seneca and I searched my memory
for that and tried to see do I have any
memories of having been in ancient Rome
like that and only one
brief moment lasted less than one second
I felt that I was in Nero's palace with
Seneca
so there's you know that's the most
meager possibility of
a past life although it felt very real
for one second
but the idea of synchronistic resonance
is that we we do have connections with
other people that Express themselves
synchronistically uh Gene Houston when I
described what had happened uh to her
well to me with Seneca she said she had
a similar connection with the ancient
Greek philosopher proclus when she was
even a child she'd hear in her had a
little voice that would say Hocus Pocus
where is brokeless and uh proclus who
was a great
neo-platonic philosopher
the last of the great neoplatonic
philosophers has become an important
psychic influence in her life and in the
same way and occasionally I run into
other people who feel deeply touched by
a historical figure where there are many
different synchronistic events that seem
to reinforce the connection
so uh that's what we called archetypal
synchronistic resonance
could you delve into your personal
encounters with psychic phenomenon and
what convinced you about the possibility
of reincarnation
well as a matter of fact I did an
interview back in the days I was doing
radio interviews for wisdom radio I was
approached by a medical doctor in San
Francisco named Walter semcu and he had
just published a book about astrology a
very clever book and I'd interviewed him
about astrology and he noticed when he
was visiting me that I happened to and I
still own the URL very early in the days
of the internet I claimed the URL for
williamjames.com William James being the
founder of American psychology a great
Pioneer in the field of Paris psychology
or as it was known in his day psychical
research and William James who was a
hero of mine I I really respected him
which is why I acquired that website and
Walter semke when he learned of it said
oh maybe you were William James in a
past Lifetime and
I thought about it and I said I don't
think so once again like Seneca he's my
hero not I wouldn't have been him I wish
I could have been but I I would if I had
been William James in the past lifetime
I imagined I'd be much more accomplished
in this lifetime and he said to me well
here's what he had was learning he he
hadn't yet published his book Return of
the revolutionaries which was research
he was engaged at the time he felt he
could identify
the past lives of different people and
in his book Return of the
revolutionaries he felt he could
identify people alive today who had been
in a past lifetime some of the founding
fathers of the American
[Music]
Nation
and so he believed uh I might have been
William James and he said the way you
could determine that in his opinion was
to look at the people who were the close
people today in your life uh the closest
ones and see if they match up with
people uh who were known to be close to
the past life person to William James he
said if you've got a number of people
who are close to you who are similar in
personality traits and in physical
features to people who were known to be
close to William James that would be a
way of identifying it because in his
view people reincarnate in cohorts if
you're part of a a group of people who
were very important and influential that
that cohort would reincarnate together
lifetime after lifetime that's what he
was observing he thought it with the
founders of the American Republic and
I did that I picked a list of about 10
people I knew very well and I did feel
that you could kind of match them up
with you know this is very imprecise
this is not scientific it's it's more
artistic and intuitive but I I came up
with 10 people who seemed to match up
people who were my mentors and my family
members and good friends who seem to be
that you could equate each one of them
with somebody who was known to have been
close to William James so
I I wouldn't regard that as conclusive
by any means but it was I found it to be
interesting I I I'm not accepted that I
was William James in her past Lifetime
and once again because I don't have any
of those memories
and
I did submit to past life regression
uh one of the people I had interviewed
Charles Tremont a medical doctor was
doing hypnotic past life regressions and
he tried to take me back over and over
to a past life as William James
and a few little bits of potentially
interesting information that I've never
been able to verify came out such as the
idea that he was called billiam as a
child
instead of William billium and
but the interesting thing I suppose was
on every session at some point I would
have to come out of hypnosis because I
was getting a stomachache of all things
I'm not prone to that but William James
was and of course I knew that about
William James I read his history so uh
in spite of all of these Clues I never
accepted and I still don't accept that I
was William James in a past life but I
did I'll give Walter permission in his
book Return of the revolutionaries to
write up his hypothesis that I was as
long as he pointed out that I personally
don't accept it which he did and he
added that of course William James
wouldn't have accepted it either so
he took my non-acceptance and his
further evidence that I was with William
James in a past Lifetime and uh all I
can say is I think it's another example
some kind of synchronistic resonance
that uh in in some ways
I I do feel like I'm following in the
footsteps of William James but it's it's
very important
to distinguish between hardcore
scientific evidence and things that you
arrive at intuitively that are are maybe
important very meaningful to you but are
not established as facts and and one way
to look at it uh scientifically would be
let's take the case
of
Madame Curie and her husband Pierre and
Marie Curie they were great scientists
Nobel laureates who discovered radium
and and really initiated a whole line of
research into radioactivity which is you
know crucial to our modern understanding
of Science and at the same time both of
the curies were engaged in psychical
research they attended seances they were
involved in mediumship
they studied the great medium of the
early 20th century euseapia Paladino and
Pierre Curie for his part it was
convinced he said I saw the table
levitate and slowly float around the
room during one of these silences that
was very meaningful to him but Marie
Curie put it this way she said until we
can reproduce it in the laboratory it is
not science
so as interesting as it was even though
you had a very crucial observation uh we
can't yet call it science so a lot of my
work is in this gray area it's not yet
science but uh it is very interesting
and very meaningful
in your Series in presence which I'll
link in the description you mentioned
fragmented reincarnation so what is that
please expand
oh okay yes so let's ask ourselves the
question what happens when we die
the Egyptian view is very interesting
for thousands of years
the Egyptian cult was very stable and
the central focus of that culture was
the afterlife one of the great documents
that has come out of that culture is the
Egyptian Book of the Dead which goes
into very Great Lengths to describe the
Journey of the Soul after death uh and
of course the enormous uh economic
activity in ancient Egypt had to do with
embalming and building pyramids and and
and so on the Greeks thought the
Egyptians were far too focused on the
afterlife and and death but
one of their ideas of the Egyptians is
that the soul is not a single entity the
Egyptians had 10 different words for
different aspects of the soul and and
the idea is that they might have
different Destinies it's possible
at least to consider that when you die
some part of you might be reincarnated
uh as one person and another part of you
might break away and be reincarnated as
part of a different person uh
I mean you can look at biological
organisms in in which this sort of thing
happens colonies of cells for example
that divide up a cell can divide it up
into many other cells and
reincarnation might work that way I I
can't say it's conclusive but it
certainly we're speculating on we have
very good
scientific evidence at this point I
regard it as scientific even though you
can't yet reproduce it in the laboratory
but clear empirical observations
let me put it that way we're not at the
point of reproducing
reincarnation in the laboratory but we
have many good
qualified observations that young
children for example report memories of
past lives so it is good reason to think
that some people at least reincarnate in
the University of Virginia
Department of perceptual studies they
have a database of some
2700 individuals uh who were young
children and almost as soon as they can
begin to talk they describe their past
lives so we might say we've got evidence
that of of the 27 I think it's 1700 were
what are regarded as solved cases which
means that the information provided
by these young children who are
sufficient for researchers or family
members who actually locate and identify
the person who the child is talking
about that they say they were in a past
lifetime so you might say we we got
empirical evidence that 1700 individuals
have reincarnated it doesn't mean
everybody will reincarnate or that
here's the thing part of you might
reincarnate and another part if you
might move a higher end in the afterlife
which according to the accounts of we
get through mediumship and other
channeling and other resources people
who have been dead
sometimes for decades come back and
start describing what it's like the
different stages they go through so
to my way of thinking
it's entirely possible that an
individual a great Soul like a William
James
might
be divided up and might Express itself
in multiple people
and in fact there are accounts after
William James died there are numerous
accounts coming from mediums and
channelers of people who feel they're in
touch with William James
so uh if you take them all seriously and
I'm not sure that we should
is I haven't studied them in detail to
get a sense of their authenticity
I think it's a possibility that uh that
it works that way other people would
disagree with me they would say that the
idea of the self a unitary self that
goes from past life to past life that's
the way it works and all I can say is at
this point we don't have enough data to
to know what what it's like I expect
when I look at the uh many many
different accounts of the afterlife I I
expect that there are more possibilities
than we can even imagine
from your cases have you identified any
uniform processes that occur after death
yeah there are there are many
uh patterns that can be observed from uh
the accounts that we have I mean 1700
solved cases is actually a fairly large
number I can tell you for example that
uh most of those cases uh involve males
and most of those cases involve uh a
violent death of the previous person
which I think is is more likely to occur
if you were a male in a previous life
you're more likely to have had a violent
death than if you were a female and also
it does seem as if the sex is the same
and 90 percent of the past lives and
about 10 percent people apparently
change sex which has led some research
researchers to speculate that cases of
homosexuality cases of uh
trans like what we call today trans
people who feel that they they are born
in in the in a body which doesn't
represent how they feel uh in terms of
their gender uh but those cases may be
people who recently transitioned from
one gender to another uh so there's some
interesting uh theorizing along those
lines
those are some of the the main things we
know but we can also say that
personalities do seem to be similar from
Lifetime to Lifetime uh the traditional
religious idea of karma that if you're a
bad person in One lifetime you're going
to be punished for it in the next
lifetime uh that doesn't seem to be
supported by the empirical evidence that
we have right now but it does seem to be
the case that the tendencies that you
had in a previous lifetime both
your desires your interests your
personality your occupational Tendencies
those seem to carry forth it's it's what
the Hindus would call samskaras the
tendencies that you bring with you the
tendencies that you have when you die
are carried forward so there is a sense
that you are largely the same person
from Lifetime to Lifetime based on you
know the limited database that we have
can you please elaborate on the
differences in reincarnation studies
between eastern and western cultures I
remember a discussion about those in
Southeast Asia where the belief in
reincarnation is widespread that is they
tend to come back quicker is that
correct
uh it is correct that the cases of
reincarnation that come from Asia and
the bulk of cases do come from Asia in
countries where reincarnation is
accepted the interim period between
lives is shorter on average it could be
I think average maybe just about months
between the death of one individual and
the you know birth of the next life uh
and in the accident in Western cultures
um it could be years
uh so so there is a real difference but
there's a limited number of cases and
one of the most famous cases in the
western literature is the James
leininger case where uh he remembered
had a vivid memory of having died in
World War II and then was uh reborn
decades later so you know because
there's a small number of cases and one
or two cases like that with the
decades in in between it it really makes
the average of the western cases much
longer uh I don't know that we have
enough data yet to draw a firm
conclusion about it but from the data we
do have in certainly there's as if
there's a distinction between the uh
Oriental and the Occidental cases how
does your belief about what may happen
after death relate what actually happens
I know you're surprised that we can
affect what occurs after death via our
beliefs how do we know if any of this is
true yes uh Professor Jeffrey
the wonderful philosopher and chair of
the religious studies department at Rice
University has made this point exactly
that the afterlife is dependent upon how
we think about it and how our cultures
seem to think about it the way I view it
is that
there's a very thin boundary between our
physical existence and the afterlife you
might say the way uh
I did some very interesting interviews
with Stephanie Stevens a jungian
psychologist who explained from the
jungian point of view the afterlife is
part of the collective unconscious that
we experience that uh we're so close to
it for example my dream of Uncle Harry
uh many many people report visitations
from deceased friends and relatives in
their dreams the boundary is that thin
and and she notes young himself when he
describes a dream he'll often say this
deceased person visited me in a dream
very specifically rather than saying I
had a dream about such and such a person
it it wasn't just a dream image young
seemed to be very clear that he could
distinguish between visitations from the
deceased versus a dream of the decision
deceased so that seems to be the
boundary between uh everyday
Consciousness and the afterlife it's a
very very thin boundary and Carl Jung in
particular developed the technique of
active imagination as a way to explore
the injury at some point as you're
imagining what it might be like you move
from the realm of imagination into what
the philosopher Henry Corbin called the
realm of the imaginable the imaginal
realm
is very subtle it's not physical but it
is very real it would be like when
Seneca appeared to be in my hypnotic
experience and said study my life uh
there was I only learned from studying
his life that there was something very
real those were his last words
so uh
Henry Corbin or example became a Sufi
part of Islamic mysticism and he was
very interested in studying the Sufi
philosophy of Illumination as developed
by the 12th century Mystic surovari and
he felt that he had entered into an
imaginable building which superiority
came to him taught him directly the
teachings of Illumination so that would
be an example where
imagination leads to something that is
more real than mere fantasy
have you formed an idea of what you call
a universal cosmological structure what
might that look like you know it's very
subtle it's shifting it doesn't stay the
same from moment to moment
but I think it's fair to say if I were
to try and map it out
schematically we have the physical world
we know or we believe actually that the
physical world is real I think most
people would agree to that that what we
experience through our senses Is Real at
least most of the time
it's physical it like you can knock on
wood and have a sense to this hardness
and physicality uh and then we have this
realm of Pure Imagination you know Walt
Disney and uh Pirates and fairies and
cartoons and and fantasy uh there's no
doubt whatsoever that human beings can
have a very active Fantasy Life and what
I'm suggesting is that there's a Third
Realm it's somewhere in between
fantasy and physicality it says real
ontologically speaking ontologically
means the philosophy of what is real
ontologically real but it's not physical
uh of course are many things like that
uh that are ontologically real and not
physical uh Plato described that as the
the realm of forms for example the
perfect circle
it will never be physical but it's a
real mathematical construct
mathematicians by large or claytonists
in in this sense so but you can build on
that you can say in addition to physical
forms in the platonic realm there are
archetypes uh there are
entities there may be ancestors there
there may be uh spirits that are also
very real autonomous non-physical
entities that exist this is what
basically the religion of spiritualism
is based on the I the idea that the
spirits of the dead or maybe even
archetypal entities or deities are very
real they're not just products of our
imagination and of course this will
always be very controversial because as
Marie Curie said until you can reproduce
it in the laboratory it's not scientific
but from a philosophical point of view I
think it has a lot of Merit
have you ever met Robert Monroe and
recognized by the way for his Infamous
out of body experiences uh I did have
the opportunity to interview Robert
Monroe back in my days at kpfa radios
one of the first people as a matter of
fact who came across and visited me in
the studio there and you got to say he
his work and out of body experiences uh
has to some extent been replicated in
the laboratory Bob Monroe worked with
Charlie tart who was one of my
dissertation advisors at Berkeley and
they set up experiments in which uh
Monroe would be asked to leave his body
and in a room where there was a shelf
near the ceiling that had been placed so
an object that was on the Shelf couldn't
be viewed from where Monroe was lying
down on a bed uh but if he could leave
his body float up to the ceiling and
look above the shelf he could see what
was on the shelf and he was asked to
report on it and he was able to
successfully report on it other more
sophisticated studies on out-of-body
experiences were conducted by Carlos
osis at the American Society for
psychical research back in the
1970s he worked with a an out-of-body
experiencer named Alex Tannis and they
developed a device
which was very interesting it it
projected images optically but in order
to know what those images were you had
to be positioned at a certain location
near the device otherwise he couldn't
see it and once again Alec tennis
was able to describe the Target now does
that mean they actually left their body
that they traveled in what esoteric
people would call the astral body or the
etheric body to a location and
excuse me to a location in physical
space
or were they simply using remote viewing
or Clairvoyance that's kind of the
conundrum
because we have very good laboratory
evidence that
Clairvoyance exists remote viewing
exists a person sitting calmly in a
chair and access information anywhere in
time and space and they don't need to
leave their body to do it
so that that creates a big complication
not only for out-of-body research but
for
all the research involving the afterlife
and survival after death but could it be
the case that
people reporting contact with spirits
and information like a spirit comes
through a medium and they describe all
kinds of details about their life when
they were alive that were unknown to
anybody in the room at the time and only
through extensive research could be
validated there are a lot of examples of
this but does that mean that it was
really that person uh their Spirit
coming through the afterlife or was it
simply a case of the medium using their
Clairvoyance to access what you could
call the akashic records or what William
James called the
Cosmic reservoir of all knowledge and
come up with that information many
people in parapsychology today argue
that
that's the way it works that we know
living people have psychic abilities and
because of that it's very hard to prove
scientifically that such a thing as uh
postmortem Consciousness is real now in
my case I don't have any question about
it and the reason is because
my experience my dream visitation with
my Uncle Harry was so powerful so
profound so far removed from normal
Consciousness that I was just crying
tears of joy
that uh for me there's no doubt but if
you haven't had such an experience uh it
would be very natural to doubt
do Eastern Traditions or religions offer
something different about understanding
post-death one of the reasons that I
produce so many videos on the new
thinking aloud Channel almost a new
video every day is
that I feel we are the inheritors of the
esoteric cultures that were developed
all over the world it's no longer the
case that just because for example I was
born into a Jewish family that I would
only be pursuing the Jewish traditions
of mysticisms and the half-life and so
on we are the inheritors of all
Traditions whether it's zoroastrian or
Hindu or shamanic or Christian or Jewish
or Islamic I I believe that
we are all Global Citizens and my goal
is to share with the audience that I
have on the new thinking aloud channel
uh all of these cultures because I I
feel that if you want to have a
complete vocabulary of the various
nuances and windows into this
extraordinarily vast world of the human
psyche you you need to understand them
all and and of course that's a
never-ending process but uh I've gained
enormously from practicing yoga from
studying meditation from being aware of
the teachings of zoroaster or
understanding the accused plant
medicines uh understanding of course
many different modern scientific
approaches biofeedback or as Robert
Monroe developed the the hemisink notion
of the binaural beat effect and how that
affects Consciousness it's incumbent
upon anyone who is a serious I would
call them psychonar an Explorer of the
inner depths to have a a certain level
of familiarity with the great world
Traditions involving consciousness
are the implications of
parapsychological tests like the
afterlife or higher conscious abilities
irreconcilable with the scientific
worldview and if not can you even claim
to scientifically study them then how do
you bridge these well imagine you're
going to uh see a movie when you when
you enter into the theater you buy your
ticket and you walk into the theater you
sit down you know that you're about to
watch a work of fiction
but what you do at that point is uh what
Scholars call a willing suspension of
disbelief while you're in the movie you
let go of that awareness that this is a
work of fiction you accept it as real
you enter into the story and uh people
well when I was a student to criminology
which is a branch of Sociology
there is a a form of research there
called participant Observer research if
you want to understand you know what
it's like to be a criminal you can hang
out with criminals and you can you can
become part of their culture and so you
will willingly suspend your disbelief in
that lifestyle you will willingly
suspend you know the idea that you're
actually a criminology graduate student
so that you can enter into their world
but then later on you can step back and
examine it from what might be thought of
as a more objective way it's you can in
other words you can have both you can
have scientific objectivity and you can
also maintain the the openness to enter
in fully to the uh subject that you're
studying it's hard to do both of those
at the same time I don't advise doing
them at the same time but you can in the
course of your investigation you will
have moments when you step back and
moments when you really enter into that
worldview I did a lengthy study a
10-year
field study with a man called Ted Owens
I've written a book about him called the
PK man and when I'm working with him
naturally you want to enter into his
world you don't want to be constantly
saying No this can't be and that can't
be and what about this or what about
that the goal is to understand him as
fully as possible and then later on to
step back and try to be more objective
about it
could you explain what macro's
psychokinesis is and if there's any
substantive evidence supporting it
macro psychokinesis is one of the most
controversial areas within
parapsychology and even long-time
parapsychologists have a very difficult
time with it it seems as if it's okay if
people can influence the fall of dice
for example uh so in a way that's
slightly specifically significant but to
the for example when Urie Yeller was
going around touching spoons or causing
them to bend without even touching them
at all
um
parapsychologists were horrified
like and and the reason they were
horrified is is because first of all if
they were to document this nobody would
believe them they would be regarded as
crazy and second of all
and probably even more important to the
ethical implications if you can bend a
spoon does that mean you can stop
somebody's art
uh or as a cartoon I saw once uh there
are a couple pilots in an airplane and
and they're saying I don't know what you
spending spoons is and then you see the
airplane kind of bending in half uh the
the ethical implications of
extraordinary parapsychological
abilities are frightening and I don't
think there's stay together with that if
somebody uh has the power of macro
psychokinesis can they heck someone and
cause them to die as is a tradition
around the world and shamanic cultures
and cultures that have a history of
sorcery and there was an anthropologist
named Ronald Rose for example who
um wrote a study of a technique known as
the pointing of the bones which was a
method used in certain cultures in the
Caribbean to hex someone to the point
where they die and at that time
anthropologists had developed a theory
that the reason people die after they've
been hexed is because first of all they
know they've been hexed and that
triggers a stress response on their part
and they die from the stress of knowing
that they've been hexed and uh Ronald
Rose accepted that theory it was
standard it's consistent with
materialism world view but then he
encountered cases in his own work as an
anthropologist in which the people who
were being hexed didn't know they were
being hex in fact they were in another
country far away uh from the
Caribbean culture where the hexing took
place and yet they died nevertheless
uh so one way to think of that is it
could be telepathic there's a theory
about healing that is that it's just a
telepathic suggestion I give you the
telepathic suggestion that you will be
healed and then you use that to activate
your own innate healing abilities
similarly with hexing you get a
telepathic message that you're being
hexed and that triggers the stress
response that causes you to die
um
so there's a fine line between macro
psychokinesis you could say and
telepathy it's hard to know where to
exactly draw the lines now in the case
of Ted Owens
he specialized in a large-scale
phenomena
he performed many demonstrations during
his lifetime of
involving things like heat waves in the
middle of winter cold waves in the
middle of summer moving hurricanes
around
tornadoes volcanoes earthquakes
large-scale power blackouts
it's very difficult to
research these things because they're
often described in kind of vague terms I
say a heat wave in the middle of winter
that could mean many different things
nevertheless over and over and over
again I have it by files over I think
well over 150 examples of such
demonstrations and it seems over and
over and over again roughly two-thirds
of the time depending on how you want to
count because there's a lot of gray
areas in there things seem to work out
as he said they would sometimes very
precisely
on one occasion he called me up on
Christmas Eve 1985. I'll never forget
this because he has his big booming
voice and he called me on the phone and
said uh Jeffrey this is the most
important phone call you will ever
receive
and he said it's up to you now
you have to inform the United States
government not to launch the next space
shuttle because if they do my UFOs he
felt that he was in contact with aliens
in a UFO he said those UFOs are going to
knock it right out of the sky yeah
I of course had no influence with the
U.S government I have never had a
relationship with the U.S government
other than uh being designated as a
conscientious objector on one occasion
and
I suppose getting Social Security but I
have no voice there and I didn't think
even if I had a voice anyone would care
what I had to say so I ignored him and
then when the Challenger space shuttle
exploded about a month later I was
shaken to my bones and the question is
was that an example of macro
psychokinesis
I can't say I mean he claimed he was in
telepathic contact with aliens and they
did it
uh so maybe it was precognition and of
course the official reports talk about
the ovary age to be explained completely
by negligence on the part of the NASA
authorities Who let that space shuttle
uh launch in the first place we'll never
know
uh but the reason I bring up this
example is because it was very precise
it was there was no question he was
referring to the Challenger
and he was very clear that if that
shuttle were launched it would be
knocked out of the sky uh so there's no
denying the the Precision of what he
said in in that instance whether it was
macro psychokinesis or precognition I
can't say and that's one of the reason
that parapsychologists use the word Psy
PSI but it's refers to the Greek letter
PSI uh as a the nomenclature that refers
to all kinds of parapsychological events
whether it's
telepathy Clairvoyance precognition
retrocognition or psychokinesis is
because philosophically they're very
hard to distinguish one from the other
and the example of the Challenger space
shuttle illustrates that very well so
there are people
in parapsychology like at may very
prominent parapsychologist who received
Government funding for many many years
to explore remote viewing
he maintains that it can all boil down
to precognition that there never has to
be an example of psychokinesis and there
are others uh like Stephen brownie the
former editor of the Journal of
scientific exploration who are more
inclined to think that psychokinesis and
macro psychokinesis is very real in his
instance as a young man he witnessed
table levitations tables in his presence
rising up he couldn't even pull them
down they seemed to be rising up of
their own accord and he could think of
how do you explain that in terms of
precognition that has got to be macro
psychokinesis that has been going on for
centuries their documented cases like
that
going back to at least the 1800s I think
much earlier in in fact but because
they're relatively rare and so unusual
most people are afraid to report it they
say if I tell people that I witness this
table levitating by itself they'll think
I'm crazy so
one of the major reasons that people are
afraid of even talking about their
psychic experiences is exactly that that
people will think I'm crazy
and macro psychokinesis is right at the
top of the list of taboo topics for that
reason
did Ted Owens give you any indication as
to when at least he claimed his ability
started Pat all wins
came from a family in in which psychic
functioning was taken for granted his
grandmother was and his grandfather was
a gausser the grandmother was something
of a medium but it often is the case
that this sort of thing runs in family
so he had native Talent
I don't think there's any question to
that but at the same time he felt that
he had been
visited by aliens he felt that they had
actually
encountered him uh on a strange occasion
when he was driving in the middle of the
desert as I recall in Texas and uh found
himself uh surrounded by tarantula
spiders and then there was missing time
and he he felt that they'd actually
operated on his brain in a way to
enhance his psychic abilities he also
felt that they had been working with him
since childhood so that he had in his
early life many different occupations
very strange things he was a bullwhip
artist in a circus Sideshow he had a
knife throwing act he was a high-speed
typist he worked as an idea man for a
railroad he was a jazz drummer at one
time and he felt that they guided him
into all of these professions so that
his mind was sufficiently flexible that
he could work with their
system of telepathic communication which
was involved symbols and he could send
symbols and receive symbols from them
and he would understand what they meant
and he knew how to craft symbols to send
to them so that they would do things
that he asked them to do that's the way
he viewed it
uh it's very interesting because uh on
the occasion that I first met Ted Owens
which was a conference in London
sponsored by the parascience foundation
at the University of London in
1976. there was another speaker at the
conference another person who is known
for macro psychokinesis her name was
Suzanne padfield she was the wife of a
well-known physicist named Ted bastard
and she had worked for over a decade in
a what was known at the time as the
laboratory of paraphysics
they had set up experiments with light
beams to see if she could bend a beam of
light with her mind now that would be
another example of macro psychokinesis
at a subtle level they claimed that they
had many examples of her bending a beam
of light
and at the same meeting where Ted Owens
introduced himself to me she stood up
and she said you know I used to think
that it was Spirits I was working with
who performed these activities like
poltergeists
but gradually I came to realize that I
was using the idea of spirits as psychic
support figures because if they were
doing it then I didn't have to take any
responsibility so that freed me out from
feeling uh guilty or feeling
self-important or anything I could
simply say well they did it I had
nothing to do with it uh she said but I
realized over time that actually it was
my Michael Kinesis and I could do it I
didn't need to credit the invisible
Spirits I could take responsibility for
it myself and she felt this was the case
with other psychics as well who would
like Ted Owens who credited it's all the
space intelligences although the way he
put it was that I have some ability but
they do the big the heavy lifting it
comes from them
uh it changed over time I was never sure
when I worked with him uh what to make
of it except for the fact that he
claimed he could produce UFO sightings
and did so on many occasions so
including one instance in which again
this could be precognition he called me
up one day we were doing in a project to
see if he could produce UFOs and he said
there's one coming he said I can feel it
he says this is going to be one of the
biggest UFO sightings ever it will be
seen by hundreds of people it will be
photographed and he said the photograph
is going to be published in the front
page of one of your local papers in the
San Francisco Bay Area well five days
later that's exactly what happened
the sighting took place on a college
campus it was being uh there was an
event being sponsored by the art
Department of the Sonoma State College
as it was called at that time it's now
Sonoma State University and the art
Department had an artist who named
Stephen Poleski who flew an airplane a
little airplane with smoke trailing out
the back and he made designs in the sky
and that was his art form and so the art
department is out there hundreds of
students with their cameras
Stephen Poleski is in the air making
designs when right in his airspace
a UFO appears and he sees it and reports
on it and people on the ground see it
and photograph it and what do you know
the photograph was published on the
front page of the Berkeley Gazette
so and not only that it was videotaped
and the videotape was broadcast on the
channel 9 aqed evening news of all
things so I'd have to say that's very
unusual that uh something like that
would happen I don't know of any other
instance offhand in which a major
City newspaper published a UFO picture
on the front page but it happened five
days after Ted Owens told me it's about
to happen
am I accurate in inferring that you
recently undertook a test to assess if
you're still receiving post-death
Communications from Ted
yes in on December 12th to be precise
last year 2022.
I got a message from one of the viewers
the new thinking aloud channel in
Germany and he told me while he was
meditating a figure of period he's a
deep meditator he's already half hour
into his meditation and he sees this
figure and
doesn't know what to make of it and
gradually he could see it's a human
being and because he was familiar with
my video channel he recognized the
figure is Ted Owens and Ted Owens told
him I have a message I want you to give
to Jeffrey and he said he sat and he
meditated on that for months because he
was afraid because it he thought it
could be a fantasy but after several
months of examining himself he
determined for himself it was no fantasy
it was real and he reached out to me and
passed on the message
and so he's the message is Jeffrey uh
Ted Owens knows that you might want to
reach out to him I didn't have any
thoughts of that until I got the message
but you can do so in meditation
and I thought well all right I'll see if
I can in meditation contact Ted Owens he
had been dead 35 years but at that time
he died in 1987.
and one day
and in fact to be precise on December
28th
2022. I felt that I had contacted Ed
Owens in meditation I felt that we had
had a conversation I felt that he had
agreed to perform a demonstration in
order to ask the space intelligences to
perform a demonstration and at the time
I was very concerned for the people of
Ukraine I was aware of the fact that
news reports said
that the invading Russians were now
destroying the Ukrainian infrastructure
their power system so they wouldn't have
heat in the winter that was coming
and I asked Ted Owens to use his
abilities which I knew he had a history
of creating pot spells in the middle of
winter to create a hot spell so that the
Ukrainian people wouldn't suffer and
that we would run a test for 90 days
from December 28th up until about the
28th of March
which is roughly a month ago and I am
now analyzing the data to see whether
there was a statistically significant uh
heat spell in in Ukraine uh
I can say this for what it's worth that
only a few days after I announced which
I did on the new thinking aloud channel
that very day I announced it on December
28th that we're going to run this trial
by January 1st
there was an unbelievable heat spell all
over Europe thousands of temperature
records were broken in one day the
problem is in my recollection of the
conversation with Ted Owens I didn't say
all over Europe I said Ukraine and uh so
it's I can't say even if you know that
he'd spell did occur uh whether it's
really related to the conversation I
believe I had with Ted Owens
um
so probably in another several weeks
we'll have analyzed the data and I'll be
able to say for sure whether or not the
weather in Ukraine was statistically
warmer uh over the winter right now I
just don't know I'm inclined to think
probably it was warmer but not
necessarily statistically significant so
but until we've completed running all
the numbers I don't know for sure
given that Ted's predictions weren't
consistent what does that say to you
what you're looking at is the question
of imprecision and yes in in real life
when you're doing case study research of
the Paranormal there very often is
imprecision if for example if you're
doing an astrology reading or an iching
reading trying to determine is this
reading accurate for me well the
readings are usually very very general
and it's very very hard to determine
with any kind of scientific Precision
whether or not they're accurate so it
gives a lot of room for the True
Believers to uh say you know it's a
perfect description of me because they
don't have to
specify he said this date and this time
and exactly this event and the
temperature change will be such and such
so in in real life we often
assume that an imprecise event means a
certain thing for us whereas in in the
scientific laboratory you can't operate
that way you have to be very very
precise if you're doing an a
psychokinesis experiment you've got
everything specified in advance what the
targets are what statistical tests
you're going to use what outcome will
satisfy your experiment and what outcome
would be a disconfirmation of your
hypothesis in real life field studies it
doesn't work that way at all so an
interesting question to ask yourself is
do we really learn more from experiments
than we do from field studies and that
I'm not sure the reason I say that is
because
the early work in what was called
psychical research in the 19th century
was largely field studied research and
they approached it with the discipline
that a a police detective would have and
doing police work you tried to get
corroboration testimony from other
Witnesses you try to see if there are
any documents that will support the
hypothesis you you look for
confirmations where you can find them
and you draw conclusions based on
your analysis of the data not so
different than the way a literary critic
might analyze a novel
and say what is what is the meaning to
be found in this novel and we have great
works that were published in in that era
for example fwh Myers in 1903 uh
posthumously published his great book
human personality and its survival of
bodily death uh and it runs for hundreds
of pages and two volumes and is a
masterful analysis of the human psyche
and how
there are there's a spectrum of events
from uh normal human consciousness to
the most extreme forms of psychokinesis
and precognition that point towards the
survival of human consciousness it seems
to be a Continuum of evidence so the the
experimental work in parapsychology
largely began in the 1930s with J.B Ryan
at Duke University doing card guessing
experiments uh they were very precise
statistical analysis conditions are well
controlled at this point over a thousand
of these experiments have been published
the results are very clear statistically
but there's a weak effect that is
consistent but it doesn't work a hundred
percent of the time and
uh now have we learned any more from the
experiments than we already knew from
the field studies I'm inclined to think
no I'm inclined to think that the basic
facts were well understood the way the
phenomena function could be well
understood through field studies but
what the experiments gave us was not a
better understanding but really a
confirmation of what we already knew to
be the case from the field studies we
could now say they've been verified
through experiments
in light of the aerial School incident
in Zimbabwe where school children
reported a UFO landing and warning about
Humanity's destructive technology what's
your perspective on this cautionary
message
the warnings concerning technology and
concerning pollution of the planet are
are very real and you find them across
many cultures I've done a series of now
40 interviews with James Tunney he is
the author of uh such books as Tech
bondage slavery of the human Spirit uh
the ID scientists is earning people into
robots so to speak that we are losing
touch with our innate capacities I
described earlier with Eugene Houston's
metaphor of the human organism as being
like a Stradivarius violin and we only
learn to play it like a plastic fiddle
and I'm afraid to say that cell phones
and television and
electronic technology the world in which
we're embedded and I feel very much a
part of of that world it's given us a
great deal but it also takes something
away from people it takes away a sense
of soulfulness a sense of there's
something larger to us than simply being
you know a successful entrepreneur or
you know many people who who are engaged
in the world of science and technology
have the attitude that he who dies with
the most toys wins that it's all about
material possessions and material
acquisition that
we lose something of ourselves and the
modern world as a whole has has been
defined this way over and over again by
different people Carl Jung the great
Swiss psychiatrist wrote the the book
Modern Man In Search of a soul
and people credit Nietzsche with saying
that God is dead
but what I think he really meant is
everybody thinks God is dead God is no
longer a living presence
in the life of people even religious
people so-called religious people
seem to be more concerned with the
suppressing uh trans children than in
for example cultivating their own spirit
uh
it's a very serious problem in our
culture imagine uh for example it means
to me having earned a doctoral diploma
in parapsychology over 40 years ago and
being really aware of the very extensive
history thousands of experiments and
field studies going back well over 150
years and all of this information is
pushed to the fringes and almost never
talked about inside of our educational
institutions even inside of our churches
inside of our scientific establishments
this knowledge is considered taboo and
at the same time
an understanding of who we are as
individuals is being lost the knowledge
of the afterlife for example is
knowledge of who we are it's knowledge
of our own psyche and uh people instead
begin to think of themselves as cogs in
a great machine you know let's keep the
economy going Let's uh get a successful
job
and I know people are disintered I hear
young people saying why should I spend
four years getting a college degree only
to be able to work in a job that I'm
going to hate for the rest of my life
that it makes people feel like their own
dignity is has to be sacrificed in order
to earn a living
that that's what our culture is like
right now and so the fact that you hear
over and over and over again from
different sources even now coming from
extraterrestrials supposedly Landing in
flying saucers that we're not paying
enough attention to our own inner nature
it's not surprising
what are some of the difficulties that
parapsychology and perhaps even the
scientific method has to overcome
you know we could talk a long time about
this subject
my mentor Arthur whom we've spoken
earlier uh felt that we have to go
beyond science
is incapable of addressing first
principles like why was the universe
created in the first place is not a
question that science can answer
and in order to begin to get a handle on
first principles it sometimes becomes
necessary to develop a mindset which uh
is more like the the way the right brain
works the right brain works in images it
the right brain is where we get messages
in our dreams
and
the psychiatrist Eric frohn wrote a book
called The Forgotten language which is
the language of Dreams this would be the
language of the most primitive people
because they all had dreams and and most
primitive times they didn't really make
such a clear distinction between waking
reality and sleeping reality the
Australian agonies with emerge from the
dream time that is the original language
that people
spoke and understood uh and it's the
language of animistic cultures
everywhere today it kind of makes no
sense whatsoever from a strict
scientific perspective and yet we see
that if you follow strict scientific
protocols yeah they're amazing
accomplishments you can build atomic
bombs at the same time
you can build giant computers but at the
same time you could build spaceships but
at the same time you're polluting the
planet and worse than that we find that
let's take the behavioral sciences
there is a crisis today in Behavioral
Science and I think many other Sciences
as well probably biological sciences
it's a crisis of replicability many
experiments that were considered models
that were considered paradigms of good
experiments and have been followed for
years and years in different fields are
now
not being replicated
and
so in the field of Behavioral Sciences
people are wondering what are the limits
of the scientific method are we running
up against an uncertainty principle
which is well known in physics
there's only so much that science can
tell us about subatomic particles if you
want to measure their position you're
not going to be able to measure their
momentum
if you try to measure their momentum you
won't be able to measure their position
are there limits like that through our
understanding of knowledge itself and
the same question was addressed by
Einstein's colleague at The Institute
for advanced studies in Princeton the
great logician whose name is on the tip
of my tongue right now um
uh I'm sorry it uh it's not coming to me
but it it'll probably I'll blurt it out
in in a few minutes or I could look it
up
um
who came up with the um
a similar principle uh to the
indeterminacy principle in physics
it's the idea that no system of
knowledge is ever capable of explaining
itself no system of logic no system of
mathematics and ever explain it itself
you always have to go to a meta stance a
larger system in order to explain any
system and what we find I think when
when extraterrestrial Communications
seem to be pointing towards the Absurd
you could say that they're pointing
towards a meta system A system that
is beyond science itself Beyond logic
itself
like yeah Mentor Arthur Young used to
call it dirty thinking
actually and and it's where sometimes it
takes a paradox it takes a joke it
requires humor or poetry or something
just to get you out of the box that
you're imprisoned The Logical box that
imprisons us that we all seem to walk
around
in a prison of our own thoughts
typically they're telling us what is
possible and what is impossible and uh
there are many people today who have
recently in fact published articles that
all the data of parapsychology the
thousands of Articles published
scientific studies they say we don't
have to pay attention to them at all
because we know it's impossible and
impossible things can't happen therefore
why bother to even look at the research
and uh
the the way to get out of that is is to
break free from The Logical constraints
that that are holding you down about
what is and what is not possible
that certainly is true in in the realm
of uh the human being you know what does
it mean to be human why are we here at
all in the first place why is there a
universe you will never answer those
questions
with from within a logical scientific
framework the answers come to us from
mythology they come to us from
what Arthur Young used to call the realm
of Mythos that's why for example he was
interested in astrology if you ask
yourself the fundamental question
of mysticism mystics say all is one we
are one with everything that's That's
the basis of every mystical tradition
ultimately and yet we find ourselves uh
as individuals how do I as a skin
encapsulated ego someone who exists
inside this body how do I relate to the
idea that I am also one with the whole
universe
well that relationship occurs through
what Arthur described he called it the
realm of Mythos
and that is uh you find that in
astrology you find that in every
mythological system those are the
stories that we tell ourselves that
connect us to a larger universe and
ultimately they tend to be stories that
are completely irrational from a
scientific perspective which is why once
again I developed the theory with
Brendan Engen of archetypal
synchronistic resonance it's as if the
universe does speak to us the universe
is conscious
but it speaks to us in riddles it speaks
to us in synchronicities
and so to have a sensitivity to that is
a way of acknowledging your connection
to the absolute
how do Christianity Buddhism and
vedantic thought relate are they in
disagreement are they in harmony
we talk about Indra is a good example of
a God who is very much in the same vein
as as the god of Jews and the god of
Christians and Indra are similar they
wield Thunderbolts they are the king of
all of the Heavenly hosts or the other
Devas or the other Gods uh and they are
of course the the god of particular
people in the earliest
days in in Ancient India Indra was the
the main god the God of all gods the
king of the Gods and in The Vedic
tradition which are the earliest
scriptures from India this this Indra is
the most frequently mentioned of all the
deities
and yet today if you go to India you
won't find any temples to Indra Indra
has has become a very diminished figure
and it happened and around the time that
the philosophers who developed the
upanishads
came came about which it took as a
period that lasted for many centuries
the development of the upanishads but
what great Lucifer's civilian
subcontinent developed was an idea that
there are philosophical principles
expressed by new deities by Brahma for
example who represented the whole
universe by Vishnu
and by Shiva these were no longer the uh
God's like Indra Indra was a God Like
Zeus or Thor as as well
and there's a story
in the yeah upanishads of the ancient
scriptures in in which Indra
conquers the evil dragon
is is like a yeah
a reptilian beast and he's out to
destroy the human race uh and he's very
very powerful in fact he swallows Indra
and Indra is only free because the other
Davis helped him escape from inside the
belly of the bridge and then he uses his
Thunders and he slays litra and now he's
the king of the gods they all celebrate
his victory over this evil demon and in
order to satisfy his need for Glory
Indra builds a magnificent Palace on top
of Mount meru the home of the Gods and
uh bishvakarma is the builder of the
palace and it's completed and he shows
it to Indra and indra's walking through
this amazing Palace and he says not
enough
he wants more he his glory is such he
needs bigger palaces and greater palaces
and vishwakarma has to keep working
making the palace more and more
magnificent for him and and finally
vishwakarma is is
worn out from all of this building it's
like Indra will never be satisfied there
will never be a palace great enough for
Indra
so he appeals to Obama the universal
principle uh and it's the principle of
brown on and in in India in the uh
upanishads Brahman is the essence of
reality
it's a great principle
and he appeals to that and Brahman has
to appeal to Vishnu Vishnu is such a
great deity Vishnu has many different
avatars who appear in physical form and
represent him and Vishnu sends one of
his avatars in down to mount meru in the
form of a beautiful little child
and Indra sees this little child outside
of his magnificent Palace and he's so
excited the child is so charming and so
beautiful that it comes to him just let
me show around this Palace and the child
is being shown around and indra's
showing isn't this marvelous and the
child says to him oh this is the most
beautiful palace that any Indra has ever
built
says what any Indra I'm Indra what do
you mean any Indra when the little child
points towards a column of ants that are
Marching In through the door of the
palace and he says to Indra well you see
these ants says every one of them was
once an Indra
and that represented a turning point for
the Theology of ancient India they move
beyond the the kind of Pantheon of gods
the ancient Vedic Pantheon is very
similar to the Greek pantheon to the
Norse pantheon and in in the early days
of the Hebrew religion uh Yahweh the god
of the Hebrews was regarded borises Our
God our cult God but he's more powerful
than your God and eventually that
emerged to a Theology of oh there is
only one God that that happened
gradually over time and so uh
the theological sophistication of
different cultures evolved
over time
is is what I'm saying so that if you
study the evolution of these theologies
uh you begin to see that they do
converge that there is a sense in which
the mystical teachings of every culture
are pointing to the same reality
it's known in modern thought as The
Perennial philosophy
but you don't find it necessarily in the
exoteric teachings if if you you know
the teachings that I learned in my early
religious training describe a different
kind of deity than one finds in in the
writings of the grace
and it's
those teachings are kept often hidden
from people for example in in the Jewish
culture there is a mystical teaching of
Kabbalah
uh but you're taught you have to be 40
years old before you're ready to even
begin to study it
it's it's felt like it's it's dangerous
if you get into it at an earlier period
and uh I think the same is true with the
teachings of the great Mystics of other
cultures uh
probably in
the teachings of Buddha for example uh
are more direct in that sense Buddha was
a Mystic but even in Buddhism you start
out with the four noble truths and then
later on you learn in Buddhism well you
can the four noble truths are not the
end-all and be all in fact everything
we've got you up until now isn't really
true the real truth of the diamond Sutra
for example
can't be expressed in words it's not a
simple teaching it's a teacher that you
only can experience directly in your
heart it can never be transmitted
through words
or through words alone
there there are other teachings that go
beyond words that go beyond philosophy
so you have them in in Buddhism what's
known as the projana paramata which
means the wisdom of going Beyond it's
the same word paragraph is the same root
word para as in parapsychology which
means Beyond psychology there you need
to go further
do the so-called gods of the occult fit
into the perennialist idea they they do
but the perennial wisdom is
that usually taught at the beginning
stages of
people YouTube
to become and and I guess here's the
reason why
as you grow up young children
have I think a natural sense of
mysticism
they come from you know they come from
the the great beyond and then they're
embodied which is why I think some young
children talk about their past lives
right away they can remember them they
can remember the state between lives but
but those are rare and often occasioned
by a violent death uh earlier on but the
goal of a young child is to learn how to
function in the physical world learn how
to tie your shoes learn how to make your
bed learn how to get along with your uh
peers for example and that becomes
almost the ultimate importance for young
people is being recognized and accepted
by their friends learning how to have
friends learning how to accomplish
things in the physical world and in so
doing that
they lose touch with the uh perennial
wisdom that was in their natural state
when they were born
I mentioned earlier Freud described that
as a state of infantile regression to
the womb it could also be thought of as
a state of mystical Oneness but as
you're growing up in life you you want
to put that aside it doesn't help you as
a young child learning how to you know
get better in sports and do well in
school and have friends to remember that
you're one with everything that gets
lost
and then you reach a point typically in
my case I think around the age of 21
or so you become an adult and at that
point
I think if people often at least many
people of my generation certainly
probably with the help of drugs as well
begin to open up to these inner
realities
and begin to develop a more
comprehensive understanding of
The Perennial philosophy
uh not that it was ever taught to me I
had to reach out for it and and find it
but if you do reach out as they say when
the student is ready the teacher appears
and uh so there are many many ways in
which people can uh become acquainted
with this very rich and substantial
tradition and today there's even a a
branch of psychology called
transpersonal psychology that that deals
with it so it's available in that form
to some young people but I should say
the American
Psychological Association refuse to
recognize trans-personal psychology as
being a legitimate discipline in in and
of itself so
like parapsychology it's also taboo
so I I guess the point I'm I'm saying is
that the uh it would be wonderful if we
had a culture in which the perennial
wisdom was available from childhood
uh to people but that's not the culture
in which we live right now that's one of
the reasons uh that people are warning
us about the direction our whole culture
is moving into we're becoming more and
more like machines and less and less
like Spiritual Beings
hopefully we can reverse
what do you think of Wolfgang Smith's
assertion that these two Realms are
antithetical so that is the Christian
and pedantic thought are antipodal
this idea of uh sort of sacrificing your
ego on the altar of spirituality uh with
the idea of uh let go of all desires
the ego is the problem uh was often
discussed in the days in which I lived
with Arthur Young At The Institute for
the study of Consciousness and he was
opposed to that idea because
the way he put it and now you're talking
to a very accomplished human being a man
who felt that he wasn't even worthy of
becoming a philosopher until he had
already invented the helicopter
he said
it's not a good idea to sacrifice your
ego on the altar of spirituality until
you have developed an ego worthy of
being sacrificed
so he he would say that uh for young
people who you know become devotees of a
guru and they give up their ego and
their devout followers of whatever path
they have chosen uh they have become
like children in a way and they have
given up their sovereignty they have
turned it over to some Spirit Master
uh in in exchange for the hope of uh
achieving Enlightenment and he uh felt
that that was a mistake that people need
to cultivate themselves and when they're
ready they will uh have opportunities to
open up more to the spiritual world but
to do it as a substitute for uh the
cultivation of why we're here on this
planet which in his view was to develop
Mastery over the physical plane
then uh he felt it was a mistake and and
that you don't get enlightened that way
you enter into
a state that you might mistake for
enlightenment
Arthur Young advocated gaining control
over the physical before earning the
right to philosophize can you elaborate
on what led him to this
I'm not sure that I am entirely prepared
to defend Arthur Young's uh position in
in that regard I find it very
inspirational at the same time I think
that people there are so many
distinctions between human beings that I
would be very hesitant to try and
prescribe a a pattern that everybody
must follow that everybody should be
like Arthur Young and uh you know and
come up with a new invention that's
something that he decided for himself
and I can't say that it made him an
enlightened person it made him a very
valuable Mentor for me but as I recall
uh he was a great Soul there's no doubt
about it I remember when Arthur Young
died a double rainbow appeared is in the
sky or a double no a double halo
appeared in the sky on the day he died
over Berkeley it was so extraordinary
and it was photographed and it appeared
in the newspaper and my friends uh who
are more traditional uh would say that
that was a sign that a great Soul had
passed and I think he was a great soul
but enlightened is is a very different
state and it means different things to
different people in Arthur Young's case
I'm under the impression that he was not
indifferent about dying he didn't want
to die as he got older he was in the 90s
uh when he didn't think he was knitting
when he died in 1995 but
I I always thought he was maybe he was
even a little bit afraid of death toward
the very end he was searching
desperately for some sort of miracle
cure that that could prolong his life
even more and it seems to me that a good
sign of Enlightenment would be a
willingness to face death or as the
Buddha would say an indifference to
whether you're dead or alive
um
so there are many degrees and many kinds
of Enlightenment and I don't want to
necessarily judge some person who at a
young age without having a accomplished
anything of importance in the physical
world like inventing the helicopter if
they choose to follow a guru and devote
their lives to that Guru it's not up to
me to judge that person but I would say
for my I find Arthur Young's advice very
worthwhile and and very meaningful and I
don't think it's inconsistent
throughout your life to to want to learn
and develop and grow
and at the same time to be aware of the
traps of the ego
I'm certain beyond all doubt that if you
want to grow spiritually you definitely
don't want to fall into ego tramps those
are the things that most
prevent a person from entering into a
state of Greater enlightenment
um
but but that can be done you can enhance
the ego
um and you can at the same time grow
spiritually and here's how I Envision it
for myself here and so I tell it to
people and and that's To Love Yourself
unconditionally and by that I mean love
your spiritual self your higher self
unconditionally unconditionally means no
matter what you do no matter what you
say no matter what you think no matter
what you feel and no matter what anybody
else says thinks does or feels with
regard to you
because you can recognize there's a part
of your being at the deepest core
that is
a a spiritual Essence that is infinite
and it is that's the part of us that is
one with everything and if we can just
recognize that and love ourselves
unconditionally because of it
we can continue to move through life to
grow to learn to uh aggress and to
cultivate ourselves without getting
caught in ego traps because to the best
of my knowledge ego traps emerge when we
don't love ourselves when we hate
ourselves or dislike ourselves and at
some level but we don't want to admit it
so therefore we need to feel important
in some way or other and it's that need
that
causes us to
separate ourselves from the Oneness
which is at the very core of our being
did Arthur achieve his spiritual States
through accomplishments as opposed to
love or faith
well I think for some people it can be
accomplishment I don't think it has to
be uh
for everyone it could be just you know
being a good son a good father a good
friend
to the people you know that that could
be enough if you love yourself
unconditionally no matter what whether
or not you accomplish anything that
gives you the opportunity to get in
touch with what might be your unique
purpose your unique Destiny in life and
being in touch with that is a source of
such Bliss such Joy it's hard to express
I I feel very fortunate that I followed
my dreams as a young man and got in
touch with my destiny which was to be a
communicator
and and to do it through television and
now through the internet and to to have
conversations like the one I'm having
with you right now that that's the
essence of my purpose so it's the most
natural thing in the world for me to do
um but it's going to be different for
every person
we're all put on this planet I think for
a a special purpose uh that we need to
discover some people say yeah that we
make a contract before we're born that
this is what we're going to do and and
we need to get in touch with what it was
we already agreed to but however you
view it it's going to be different for
each person
according to a story in the talmud we're
surrounded by innumerable demons effect
too frightening for us to accept what
does this say about fear
well I can tell you this I have never
read that statement uh on the air I'm
not even familiar with it here's what
I'm familiar with when it comes to
talmudic Legends and that is that for
each human being there is an angel
and uh that angel walks in front of us
everywhere we go and says behold here
comes the image of God
so uh you can view their way because I'm
I'm not saying that that we are free
from Temptations we are I would even go
so far as to agree with Rudolph Steiner
the Austrian Mystic who was a big
influence in my life that each and every
one of our thoughts is itself a
spiritual entity and that uh when we
have a negative thought a thought that
might say oh I'm really stupid or uh
something to that effect that that is a
demonic entity trying to gain control
over us uh by making us hate ourselves
by making us feel guilty about ourselves
and so my practice is when I have such a
thought I say to myself answer bad
thought I'm alert I watch the thoughts
that pass through me and when they
happen to be negative thoughts I make a
point of uh acknowledging that I don't
own that thought that thought is not me
and that means they're not buying into
the negativity that we are surrounded
I'd like to switch gears just a bit what
are some of the common limitations to
psi ability for instance when I
interviewed Thomas Campbell he said I
can't demonstrate it for you now because
who knows we could be cheating and
people wouldn't believe it anyway which
I found to be extremely disappointing
what we're talking about our blocks to
psychic functioning and the most basic
finding of parapsychology research is
known as the sheep goat effect and uh
it's very simple as sheep are regarded
as individuals who believe that they can
do it
they're put into an experiment where
they're asked to guess uh what card is
going to come up or guess what a Target
at a remote location is about people who
believe that they can do it do better in
those tests and people who believe that
this is something they certainly cannot
do tend to do worse in fact sometimes
they actually score below chance
significantly so it's what we call Psy
missing which suggests that actually the
correct information is coming into their
subconscious mind and then they're
blocking it so that they get the wrong
answer more often than could be expected
by chance alone so that that would be
one of the first major blocks is what we
say to ourselves if if you begin to at
least acknowledge there's a possibility
that you can do this you're already a
step ahead
the other thing that the research itself
suggests and this is quite consistent
with the ancient yoga sutras is that
when you can relax and quiet your mind
you're going to be a better
telepathic and clairvoyant
receiver of information
conversely it also seems to be the case
that if you're in a state of
extreme emotion for example if you're in
an emotional crisis
maybe you've had an accident maybe
you're dying then you tend to be more of
a telepathic transmitter
so that's an interesting observation
that's that's been made now there are
many other blocks to psychic functioning
uh people are afraid of parapsychology
afraid of Psy for different reasons uh
one big reason is if you've been raised
in a fundamentalist religious tradition
you might believe that any kind of
psychic functioning is demonic and
you're afraid of it for that reason you
begin to have psychic insights ethically
parents and Afraid when their children
show a lot of psychic precociousness
they don't like it and they tell their
children to stop doing it for example
there are many cases like that and
here's another very unusual finding with
regard to people who report lots of
spontaneous psychic experiences a very
high percentage of um
Early Child trauma they come from
abusive families for example and what
seems to be the case in those instances
when you're a young child and you're
being traumatized you retreat
from the world you find safety in an
inner World in a world of your own
imagination for example with invisible
friends for example or uh just
retreating into your own shell well when
you do that as I discussed earlier with
you you enter into the realm of the
imagination and the imagination is a
doorway into what we call the imaginal
which is a psychic realm you may find
yourself first finding comfort from
imaginary friends and the next thing it
might be an actual spiritual entity
hopefully not a demonic entity
now
other blocks also are related to
things like stress
to be you know having high stress levels
and sometimes precipitates psychic
functioning at the same time as I
mentioned earlier they if you're all
stressed out your mind is noisy it's
it's hard to quiet your mind and so
people who are good meditators people
who are good at self-hypnosis people who
understand
principles of relaxation like the
jacobsonian relaxation principles uh are
all or basic stress management
principles are all better at psychic
functioning uh and another thing the
research tells us is that people who are
artistically inclined artists and
musicians people who use the right brain
more I'm saying the right brain but I'm
touching the left side of my head
uh people who who are activating the
right brain
seem to be more open to psychic
functioning well they perform better in
simple experimental laboratory tests and
uh it's probably because they're more
open to the intuitive side of life to
the irrational side of life people who
are very mechanical very materialistic
Engineers for example if you were to do
a test comparing Engineers versus
artists and musicians I would predict
that the artists and musicians will do
more uh show more psychic functioning in
the laboratory the engineers are likely
to show Psy missing but there's another
element to this and it has to do with
self-confidence in general if you are a
highly successful professional
chances are you're going to do well in
psychic functioning because you're
already using your intuition to be a
successful person in life
so a study was done for example with
business Executives business Executives
were divided into two groups those whose
companies were profitable and those
whose companies were losing money and
they were given tests computerized tests
of precognition in which the the
computer chose a Target the person was
asked to identify the Target in advance
the executives from the successful
businesses scored positively and the
executives whose businesses were losing
money showed Psy missing in in that test
so I think to the extent that people
learn how naturally to incorporate
intuition into their lives uh is is a
reflection of how well they will do when
when they're tested in the laboratory
What factors contribute to enhancing
ability
well there's always stuff that we're
going to miss we haven't talked about
diet there are people who believe that a
vegetarian diet for example promotes
psychic functioning that if you eat too
much you can fill all these animal
hormones particularly the hormones that
are in their body as they're being
killed uh which would be hormones
associated with the emotions of fear and
aggression and and that that interferes
with psychic functioning I don't know if
it's true because it hasn't yet really
been studied carefully in the laboratory
but there's a lot of folklore to suggest
that sort of thing
um on the other hand just because a
person
thinks of themselves as highly psychic
doesn't mean that they're going to
perform well in a laboratory there are
many people who are professional
psychics who have a long track record of
doing what they do the way they do it
the way they want to do it uh if you put
such an individual in a laboratory where
they're asked to perform a task uh at
the that was designed by the researchers
and is not necessarily compatible with
the normal way of working they may not
do well at all which I think
occasionally leads researchers to become
cynical about people who Proclaim to be
psychic and of course I also have to be
very clear there are all kinds of ways
in which we can delude ourselves about
are we really psychic or not uh if for
example if Ted Owens uh says to me I'm
going to create warmer weather in
Ukraine and then what we discover is oh
there was warmer weather in Germany
there was warmer weather in France there
was warmer weather in the Netherlands
there was warmer weather in Baylor
Russia uh therefore I must have done it
is it's very easy to fall into those
kinds of patterns just to take a what
was basically a miss and call it an ear
hit and say yeah that shows that I'm
psychic you see a lot of that people who
are reaching to find ways to identify
themselves as as psychic every
researcher in parapsychology has been
approached by someone who says I'm
psychic you got to test me I'm really
great and it turns out that maybe
they've deluded themselves in one way or
another so I think the lesson there is
that the human potential for greatness
is balanced by a human potential for
filing
uh and when you move into this field you
need to be aware of both of those
potentials so that you can avoid the
Folly and follow the path that leads to
whatever greatness is for you
it's peculiar and even convenient some
would say that paranormal phenomenon
everywhere evade captures such as on
Skinwalker Ranch so how do you interpret
this
well I I will say this there are
occasions such as the skinwalker
experience where there were all kinds of
phenomena that somehow occurred and made
sure that the researchers knew that they
occurred and yet avoided capture on
camera but there are many many other
instances in which people do photograph
orbs and photograph UFOs and other kinds
of paranormal entities
so it it's not as if there's a rule that
you can never photograph them
it seems as if uh each of these
manifestations has its own unique
personality
since you began your journey especially
with new thinking aloud your YouTube
channel which is linked in the
description what lessons or discussions
are there that were difficult for you to
accept I suppose I never appreciated
throughout my life whenever I chose to
follow my own passion the extent to
which uh there would be people
definitely opposed to me going in that
direction and I mean it began for
example as an undergraduate when I
decided to join various student protests
and discovered that oh you're about to
be punished because you took part in a
protest
uh
and when I went into parapsychology I
imagined what everybody should applaud
this a young person moving into a an
exciting New Field and coming up with
new discoveries and and then I realized
oh no there's a significant percentage
of the population who are
definitely opposed who feel that this
this has no place in the university and
and it went to Great Lengths to just try
and in effect destroy my academic career
and I can tell you that I I now
appreciate that virtually everybody in
parapsychology with maybe one or two
exceptions I know of one or two
exceptions where they've never
encountered any negativity of this sort
but most people have encountered uh that
sort of negativity people the
I don't want to say violently I've never
encountered any violence but short of
violence uh people have uh you know gone
to Great Lengths to try and uh suppress
the findings of parapsychology and and
to suppress individuals working in the
field of parapsychology I didn't realize
how serious it was but now I know I mean
for example JB Ryan who founded modern
American parapsychology in the 1930s at
Duke University sought psychiatric help
in order for him to deal with the stress
he was facing from critics who accused
him of all sorts of Fraud and uh
well fraud basically being you know one
of the very worst accusations you can
ever throw at a scientist so right not
only have to face people accusing him of
fraud he had to face on occasion people
who were working for him who were
engaged in actual fraud and uh he he did
that in the most open honest forthright
manner you could he dismissed those
people and he uh published the fact that
they had been caught engaging in fraud
and that none of their previous research
could therefore be relied upon he would
very explicit in the rare instances in
which that happened but the truth is
that whatever field you're in you're
going to have to encounter the
um
human nature and human nature is
extraordinarily vast and and complex and
it definitely has a dark side
is there a collective Freudian impulse
that shrouds the truth presuming we are
all interconnected and what about in the
opposite direction is there an Impulse
for us to want to believe that we're all
connected perhaps even more so than we
are
you know I've often thought of it that
way uh Freud made a point of saying that
we don't want to know what's in our own
mind the whole notion of the Freudian
subconscious is
based on the idea that we have many
impulses particularly erotic impulses an
aggressive impulses that are not
socially acceptable
he explained this very clearly in his
book civilization and its discontents we
we made a trade-off we become civilized
we have all the benefits of civilization
but it means we have to suppress and
deny certain aspects of our own nature
and that's the becomes the Freudian
unconscious and then Jung took it a step
further and he said yeah we don't want
to know about our spiritual nature
either so the jungian collective
unconscious is filled with aspects of
our own spirituality that we don't want
to know about
and so the very idea that
another person could read your mind they
could know the things about you that you
don't even want to acknowledge about
yourself
that's very frightening that's very
intimidating to people and as a culture
if we were to allow
uh human beings on this planet to
develop their full psychic potentials if
for example all young children who
showed psychic promises children were
given the same support and encourage
that would have an event applicability
or mathematical ability or artistic
ability in our culture so that we
develop the culture full of psychic
individuals how would that threaten
people
who don't want to be in such a culture
because they don't want to be seen
by everyone that they want to keep their
privacy they want to be able to hide
from people with regard to their
aggressives thoughts their sexual
thoughts that are not permissible or
even behaviors
I think uh did I tell you already at the
time I interviewed or it wasn't an
interview it was an occasion on which
Arthur C Clarke the great science
fiction writer spoke at the Berkeley
campus
it was a time when
he had just published an article in Time
Magazine debunking the claims of URI
Geller that had also been reported in
nature
at that time the early research with
Galler and Arthur Clark didn't want any
uh part of it he didn't believe it could
be real and so he spoke on the Berkeley
campus and after his talk I raised my
hand and said Mr Clark do you believe in
ESP
and his answer was so revealing he said
no I do not believe in ESP because I
don't want anybody to read my mind
and think of it it seems absurd of
course you know just because you
disbelieve doesn't mean someone can't
read your mind but at a cultural level
there's something to that you can
suppress people's psychic abilities by
creating a culture in which it's
considered unreal in which people are
punished for even thinking about it and
in which there's no
support or very limited support or
encouragement for people who show Talent
so if nobody believes that it's really
possible
then fewer and fewer people are going to
cultivate that ability and you're at
less risk that some talented psychic is
going to come along and discover your
hidden secrets
it seems that most spiritual paths
require going through some dark night
why is that I I would agree with you
that we avoid confronting our own dark
side and yet in spiritual Traditions the
tradition the Western Occidental
tradition of initiation which the
Austrian Mystic Rudolph signer wrote it
about it he said when you
become initiated into a spiritual
tradition there's always the guardian of
the threshold that you have to encounter
and the guardian of the threshold can be
the most ugly evil looking being that
you've ever known in your life another
uh example of this is the phrase there
are demons guarding every Temple uh and
you'll see this even in the great
Cathedrals there are gargoyles all
around the the great Cathedrals that are
demonic uh looking and in Asia it's very
explicit big demonic statues in in front
of the Buddhist temples they are
considered Servants of the Buddha but
they scare away the uninitiated the
people who aren't ready you have to
ultimately confront your own Darkness
your own shadow your own demons so to
speak
it's very explicit for example in the
concept program people who are becoming
addictions where they say you have to
take a a hard uncompromising look at
yourself and then you have to begin to
make amends for all the things that
you've done
as a result of that and people see the
12-step program is a very authentic
spiritual path
and of course they're forced into it
because uh you know they've hit bottoms
so to speak because of their addictions
and now they're they're working to
overcome their addictions and using the
power of the spirit to overcome
addictions and there's a a lot of
research suggesting that this is an
approach that works
even in the Bible angels are often
depicted as alarming and horrifying
Terence McKenna mentioned that we're so
estranged that we don't recognize our
inner selves when we encounter them what
are your thoughts on this
yeah Terence made a beautiful comment
that we are so alienated from ourselves
that when we see who we are in our own
depths we think it's an extraterrestrial
how should we distinguish between the
monad the spirit and the soul
well words like Spirit Soul monad psyche
uh in Hebrew the nephesh the breath
uh
in Greek
are all
context dependent they're dependent on
how they're being used by a person who
is to use them
uh the word monad for example was
largely
popularized in in the writings of uh the
18th century philosopher Wilhelm
Gottfried leibniz
the or was he 17th century I'm not even
sure uh at at this point but
uh one of the things Arthur Young my
mentor made a big point of
distinguishing between is the notion of
the difference between the spirit and
the soul and I find that a very useful
distinction that's often glossed over
people talk about the soul as if for
example it's infinite they talk about
the soul as if it's Eternal that you
have an eternal Soul well I think of the
spirit as being that infinite Eternal
part of us and I think it's the depth
within each of us and and the irony is
uh well it's not so ironical to the
ancient Hindus who understood that the
Atman that was their word for the
essence of the individual they said the
Atman is the same as Brahman the essence
of who you are is the same as the
essence of the whole universe
and uh I like that idea but that is a
reference to what I would call the
spirit and by Arthur Young meant that
very precisely as Spirit he which he
acquainted or equated with light itself
and and light if you know anything about
uh uh Einstein's theory of relativity
you know that a beam of light can travel
the life of the universe and while we're
sitting on Earth and watching it it
might take 13 billion years to go or
longer to go from one end of the
universe to the other but if you are on
a beam of light and you have a wrist
watch time can stand still so from the
perspective of the beam of light you can
travel the whole universe in no time at
all instantly from your point of view
it's one one of the paradoxes of time
itself but the point I'm trying to make
here is that there is is this part of us
that's infinite and eternal now is that
the same part of us that goes from
Lifetime to Lifetime uh in reincarnation
that progresses I'm not so sure I think
that it's very likely that the soul uh
might last a long time it might last for
thousands of lifetimes but at some point
in the evolution of the Soul we merge to
become ultimately
where we came from ultimately from our
source which is
uh one with everything
and we may discover that that everything
we're one with is completely outside of
time and space that our notion of time
and space as it seems to us while we're
here in the body is what the Hindus call
Maya it's something of an illusion it's
not what we think it is
but uh ultimately
we have that within us and we have uh
something else within us which is very
long lasting which is uh goes well
beyond the length of an individual
lifetime but it's and I would call it
the soul it's our passions our desires
are what moves us uh and and what moves
us from Lifetime to Lifetime but at some
point we let go of that
completely and become just one with pure
spirit so that's how I see it what are
the main organizations currently
studying parapsychology
well the main organization of
parapsychology is the parapsychological
association it is an affiliate
organization of the American Association
for the advancement of science it was
originally founded in I think the 1950s
by JB Ryan and his colleagues at Duke
University
it became formally affiliated with the
aaas the American Association for the
advancement of Science in
1969 it's got about 400 members so
that's the major scientific body but
there are others there is the
Society for scientific exploration it
publishes a journal of scientific
exploration and it was founded if I
remember correctly you know I think in
the 1970s by researchers who were
studying the Paranormal but a
parapsychologists are very explicit they
want to study extra sensory perception
and psychosis basically yes some the
question of life after death but there
are other areas of the Paranormal UFOs
cryptos ohology the study of for example
Bigfoot and other
beings that seem to pass back and forth
between different dimensions uh the
study of orbs the study of angels demons
those are all areas that could be
submitted to scientific inquiry and time
travel might be yet another and so the
society for scientific exploration was
formed as a way of including all of
these Fringe areas of Science Under One
Umbrella and and it's a very useful
organization there's also in England in
particular the uh although it's an
international organization the society
or psychical research the spr was
founded in 1882 and it really initiated
the scientific study of the Paranormal
it's been publishing journals and
proceedings ever since so in that
organization alone we have 140 plus
years of research data uh very valuable
organization a very important
organization uh of course all of these
organizations operate in concert with
each other and yeah there's a lot of
overlap sometimes they hold conventions
together there is also the International
Association for remote viewing which is
now or irva irva International remote
viewing Association is mostly for
practitioners of remote viewing but also
researchers in addition there's the
International Association for near-death
studies once again mostly experiencers
people who have had the near-death
experience but also researchers are
involved
in addition there are several
organizations devoted to the study of
Consciousness itself and many of them
started out with the idea that well
we're basically neurology if you want to
study Consciousness you study the brain
and the nervous system but more and more
they've come to realize you can't
exclude the Paranormal it just comes up
too often over and over again so many of
the organizations devoted to the
scientific study of Consciousness are
now also including
parapsychology
researchers in their presentations and
their conventions and so on
do you believe the government is still
conducting remote viewing research to me
it's not strange because they
investigate almost anything that may pay
off so I don't see it as an endorsement
personally what are your views
well we know that the government is now
launched some new official programs to
look into UFOs or what they are calling
uaps unidentified aerial phenomena which
could include orbs which could include
the angels for all I know or even ghosts
uh so there there is some funding coming
through uh for that and there was
recently the awesome program that was
run by the Bigelow
Aerospace corporation that
looked looked into all of that and I
think OSAP is no longer in existence
um the Bigelow has now established the
Bigelow Institute for Consciousness
studies but that that's not receiving to
my knowledge any government funding we
do know that the government-funded room
viewing programs at SRI International
and later on at saic science
applications international corporation
so for 20 years
that funding uh occurred and as a low
level maybe a million dollars a year
which is not a lot in scientific funding
supposedly that stopped long ago
basically I think 1996 or so uh and
we don't hear about any more Government
funding of parapsychology since then now
in my opinion the government would be
very smart if they wanted to continue to
fund such programs to do it
secretly because the programs are still
so controversial that funding them
publicly would just generate all sorts
of noise and media attention that would
not be beneficial to the actual research
so I hope that there is a secret program
uh within not just our government but
other governments as as well uh I have
no knowledge that that is happening uh
however what's pretty clear to me is
that all across the spectrum of
governments and Military organizations
there are individuals often highly
placed individuals who have a personal
interest and who have certain amount of
latitude in their organizations that
they're they can pursue uh quietly those
interests because they might develop
into something useful so I think that
there probably I would guess there are a
thousand people like that embedded in
different government and scientific
organizations around the world who are
pursuing this uh at a personal level
uh however uh to to move beyond the
personal level to get an actual budget
specified for This research is is
another bigger step
and I'm just not aware of that
are you planning to continue your
research with the Bigelow Institute have
they reached out to you well we're
always on the lookout for white crows
and uh I think the Bigelow Institute one
thing you can say about it it is
potentially very well funded it
potentially has a real future uh we're
certainly thinking in terms of long-term
research projects uh but I can't be more
specific than that
are you familiar with Linda Moulton
Howell's work
I I'm aware of her work I don't know her
personally and I would like to know more
about her personal work actually
I think that she's an example of how far
an individual can go to explore a topic
which was about as bizarre as anything
that anybody has ever looked at uh and
she's come up to my knowledge with with
a lot of data about it but not any
really hard conclusions
uh yes so I think uh I'm an example as
well in terms of what an individual can
do without a great deal of outside
funding uh I and in fact the whole new
thinking aloud Channel what we're doing
today publishing a magazine a Weekly
Newsletter a book series and putting up
uh at many videos every week uh it's all
volunteer effort uh enabling this we
don't have a large budget of of any sort
so I'm a strong believer in in what
individuals can do on their own and what
volunteers can do without big budgets
in fact sometimes like having a big
budget gets in the way of accomplishing
of course not always sometimes you can't
do things without a big budget but it's
amazing how much you can do uh just by
people who are dedicated and are willing
to devote their lives to this work I had
no idea that your channel is run
entirely by volunteers that's
commendable man
absolutely that's uh all that we do at
new thinking allowed uh is let me put it
this way it's 95 all volunteer effort
what I I hope to be able to uh pay
people occasionally when uh we had a
book about to be published uh called is
there life after death and so we'll be
having royalty income coming in that
will be distributed amongst the
volunteers who have worked to make that
book possible you know the volunteers
hopefully will be getting something back
for all the time and effort they've put
in there we're working like
professionals but they're doing it
because they love what they do
and uh that's that's the way great
things get done in my mind
what's a peak in Darien experience
yes
the idea of a peak in Darien comes from
a poem written uh I don't know years or
more Ago by John Key episode took place
in uh the early days of the great
explorers Cortez I think could be what
15th 16th century uh when he discovered
Panama Darian is a province in the
country of Panama and when Cortez and
his men
arrived at that Province they they saw
mountains so they climbed the mountain
when they got to the top of the mountain
what did they see
to their surprise but the Pacific Ocean
they had no idea it was even there so a
peak and Darian experience has come to
mean when you are unexpectedly surprised
by something you didn't believe would be
there and in particular it refers to
deathbed visions
uh in which typically people who are
dying experience their loved ones
waiting to greet them in the afterlife
it's very commonly reported but on a
kitchen they report wait there's my
cousin John why is he there to greet me
he's not dead
but then
it turns out to be the case that cousin
John actually had died unbeknownst to
the person who was having the vision
so there are many examples of this where
people have uh they're having visions
related to the afterlife because they're
dying or they've had a near-death
experience and they've been in the
afterlife and they come back and they
say huh this person was in my
near-death experience but they're not
dead I wonder how they got there and
then we learned oh they were dead so
those experiences are very important
because they help us to overcome the
skeptical critique that well a person
who
is is dying uh would expect to see their
relatives and friends coming to greet
them that's sort of cultural so uh it
doesn't count as evidence or uh survival
but if they see someone they didn't
expect or they didn't know uh would be
dead but who they we later learned
really was dead that would count as a
little piece of evidence pointing
towards the existence of a very
ontologically real afterlife
how are you planning for the channel to
continue man and how are you personally
preparing for death Jeff
well
my basic rule of thumb is to be here and
now ramdas put it beautifully yeah in
his book be here now we have puppies on
the
new Thinking Out Loud Channel a series
of my monologues they're called in
presence
which is my way of saying here and now
uh so I'm not really concerned a lot
about the future I'm really much more
concerned with the present about what
we're already doing we're already
publishing a Weekly Newsletter a
quarterly magazine many interviews a
week including monologues that I do or
they're really dialogues with myself in
these days and
were we have a book series as as well
the first volume is about to be
published it's already pre uh you can
order Advanced copies now on Amazon is
there life after death the first volume
in the new thinking aloud dialogues
Series so I'm just attending to those
things and uh taking it as a Here and
Now
experience being with you in the Here
and Now for example if I can do that
well that'll be enough for me
could you share a few book
recommendations
a a really good book that I uh encourage
people to read who feel they're on the
path is uh one written by the Austrian
Mystic Rudolph Steiner called knowledge
of the higher worlds and its attainment
I think I think that's a very good book
for people
I encourage people to make it a point to
read hundreds of books we offer a book
recommendation every week in in our
newsletter and uh I'm hopeful that we
are reaching out to a community of
people who don't want to say that their
knowledge of essential and paranormal
matters is limited to one book but
they're willing to read hundreds
that's how you really immerse yourself
in in this area
all right what are your hopes for the
future and again thank you so much man
for coming on the podcast
well I am imagine that the human race as
a species that we are capable of
uh expanding our psychic capacities that
when you see people occasionally the Ted
Owens and the URI Gellers and the Ingo
swans and many other highly talented uh
psychic people in in the world I see
them as exemplars of what could be uh
the masses of people and I can imagine a
time in the in the distant future I
don't think it's going to happen in my
lifetime that where where young people
everywhere who exhibit some level of
interest and talent in this field will
be encouraged we could have a psychic
Olympics the way we have an Olympics for
other endeavors and uh I think it would
be a good thing overall but it will
require a different kind of humanity a
Humanity where all people are willing to
acknowledge the spirit side of life a
Humanity in which people don't see
themselves as they often do today is
nothing more than a machine made out of
meat
the podcast is now concluded thank you
for watching if you haven't subscribed
or click that like button now would be a
great time to do so as each subscribe
and like helps you to push this content
to more people you should also know that
there's a remarkably active Discord and
subreddit for theories of everything
where people explicate toes disagree
respectfully about theories and build as
a community our own toes links to both
are in the description also I recently
found out that external links count
plenty toward the algorithm which means
that when you share on Twitter on
Facebook on Reddit Etc it shows YouTube
that people are talking about this
outside of YouTube which in turn greatly
AIDS the Distribution on YouTube as well
last but not least you should know that
this podcast is on iTunes it's on
Spotify it's on every one of the audio
platforms just type in theories of
everything and you'll find it often I
gain from re-watching lectures and
podcasts and I read that in the comments
hey toe listeners also gain from
replaying so how about instead
re-listening on those platforms iTunes
Spotify Google podcast whichever podcast
catcher you use if you'd like to support
more conversations like this then do
consider visiting patreon.com
kurtjimungle and donating with whatever
you like again it's support from the
sponsors and you that allow me to work
on toe full time you get early access to
ad-free audio episodes there as well for
instance this episode was released a few
days earlier every dollar helps far more
than you think either way your
viewership is generosity enough
foreign